NEIL GAIMAN: Thank you
so much for having us.
It's always fun to do
these Google things.
It's always
particular fun for me
when I'm out at Mountain View
because my little boy-- who
is not actually a little
boy, he's 6 foot 2 and 30,
but in my head,
he's my little boy--
is actually one of you,
which is terrifying.
So, right.
We figured out
the running order,
and tossed dice to see who
goes first, and it's me.
So I'm going to
begin with a poem,
and it's about an
awful lot of things.
I love the fact that
this poem is now--
people send me messages on
Twitter saying that they read
it at weddings, and
other people seem
to regard it as a poem
about upset and ignorance.
And I think, probably,
it's about a lot of things,
including getting off
your phone some time.
But it's called "The
Day The Saucers Came."
That day the saucers
landed, hundreds of them,
golden, silent, coming down from
the sky like great snowflakes.
And the people of Earth stood
and stared as they descended,
waiting, dry-mouthed to find
what waited inside for us,
and none of us knowing if
we would be here tomorrow.
But you didn't notice
it because that day,
the day the saucers came, by
some coincidence was the day
that the graves
gave up their dead
and the zombies pushed up
through soft earth, or erupted,
shambling and
dull-eyed, unstoppable,
came towards us, the living,
and we screamed and ran.
But you did not notice
this, because, on the saucer
day, which was the zombie
day, it was Ragnarok also.
And the television
screens showed us
a ship built of dead men's
nails, a serpent, a wolf,
all bigger than the
mind could hold,
and the cameraman could
not get far enough away.
And then the gods came out.
But you did not see them
coming because, on the
saucer-zombie-battling-gods day,
the floodgates broke and each
of us was engulfed by genies
and sprites offering us wishes
and wonders and eternities and
charm and cleverness and true,
brave hearts and pots of gold,
while giants feefofummed across
the land, and killer bees.
But you had no idea
of any of this,
because that day, the
saucer day, the zombie day,
the Ragnarok and fairies
day, the day the great winds
came, and snows, and the
cities turned to crystal,
the day all plants died,
plastics dissolved,
the day the computers turned,
the screens telling us we
would obey, the day
angels, drunk and muddled,
stumbled from the bars and
all the bells of London
were sounded, the day animals
spoke to us in Assyrian,
the Yeti day, the
fluttering capes and arrival
of the time machine day.
You didn't notice any
of this because you
were sitting in your room
not doing anything, not
even reading, not really, just
looking at your telephone,
wondering if I
was going to call.
So, the next thing
that's going to happen
is Amanda is going
to play a song.
AMANDA PALMER: Yeah,
and you should intro it,
but we should tell them
about the recording
and why this all
happened, maybe.
Or should we just
not bother with that?
We made a record,
kind of by accident.
We went on a tour and
decided to record it
and that's what this record is.
And--
NEIL GAIMAN: Yeah,
there is a record
called, "An Evening With Neil
Gaiman and Amanda Palmer."
Three discs-- one of me,
one of her, one of us.
And this is a song
that's actually
on the "us" one, because
on the record I sing it,
but Amanda's going to be
singing it now because--
AMANDA PALMER: He's nervous!
NEIL GAIMAN: She has a much,
much prettier voice than I do.
AMANDA PALMER: I think
your voice is beautiful.
NEIL GAIMAN: And it was
a song that, actually,
is kind of relevant
to everybody here.
And it began when I started
thinking about torch songs,
because classic torch songs
are, basically, conversations
that you have with a bartender
at 3 o'clock in the morning,
smoking a cigarette,
not wanting to go home
with your heart broken.
And I thought-- that
doesn't happen anymore.
You can't smoke in bars.
And if your heart
is broken, you're
not going to be in a bar at
3 o'clock in the morning.
You're going to be doing
something else entirely.
[MUSIC - AMANDA
PALMER, "I GOOGLE YOU"]
AMANDA PALMER: Thank you.
So that song was
actually written by Neil,
and I heard it in the best way.
It was the first week that
we actually met and hung out.
We weren't dating yet, this
was, like, five years ago.
And he came to stay
at my house for a week
while we were working on
this book project together.
And I don't remember how it
came up, but we started chatting
and he mentioned
that he'd written
a song for a cabaret
singer to sing,
and I said, well,
just sing it for me.
And he went, I
can't, I can't sing.
And then he opened his mouth
and just sang it a cappella,
and I couldn't believe what
a beautiful voice he had.
And he's a pretty
clever writer, too.
Anyway, so I put
some chords under it
and that was sort of like
our first weird little thing
that we did together.
And I'm going to play
you one of mine now,
and then Neil's going to read.
I was thinking about maybe
taking requests from you guys,
but I thought that that
might just get really weird.
Because, also, I'm only
going to play one song.
So I was just
standing back there,
wondering what
would actually work.
There's a song I was
practicing for the show
tonight that I
think would be good.
It might be a little sloppy,
but it's on the record
so-- I thought that
would be relevant.
And it's a song that
I wrote a couple years
ago about all these
journalists asking me
who my influences are.
And especially-- I
get asked a lot, who
are your female influences.
And I realized I'd been
thinking about it really
narrowly, and
especially the more you
give the answer to the
question, you're like,
OK-- Laurie Anderson,
and Madonna,
and la di di di
di-- all this shit
that I listened to
when I was a kid.
And you start just having a
fucking laundry list of people.
And it occurred to me, actually,
in the middle of the night
one night, that I was
leaving out this giant one,
and it struck me as
actually so important
I decided to write
a song about it.
So this is it.
[MUSIC - AMANDA
PALMER, "JUDY BLUME"]
AMANDA PALMER: Thank you.
NEIL GAIMAN: So at the
beginning of this year,
I tried an experiment, with
BlackBerry sponsoring me.
I went to Twitter, threw
out 12 questions on Twitter,
and got hundreds and
thousands of replies back.
And then picked the replies--
picked 12 replies pretty much
at random, and used
them as yogurt starter
for 12 short stories, one
for each month of the year.
And I made a calendar of tales.
And this is last month's tale.
"That feels good," I said,
and I stretched my neck
to get out the
last of the cramp.
It didn't just feel good,
it felt great, actually.
I'd been squashed up inside
that lamp for so long.
You start to think that nobody's
ever going to run it again.
"You're a genie,"
said the young lady
with the polishing-cloth
in her hand.
"I am.
You're a smart girl, toots.
What gave me away?" "The
arriving in a puff of smoke,"
she said. "And you
look like a genie.
You've got the turban
and the pointy shoes. "
I folded my arms and blinked.
Now I was wearing blue
jeans, gray sneakers,
and a faded gray
sweater-- the male uniform
of this time and this place.
I raised my hand to my
forehead, and I bowed deeply.
"I am the genie of the
lamp, " I told her.
"Rejoice, O fortunate one.
I have it in my power to
grant you three wishes.
And don't try the 'wish for
more wishes' thing- I won't play
and you'll lose a wish.
Right.
Go for it. " I
folded my arms again.
"No," she said. "I mean thanks
and all that, but it's fine.
I'm good." "Honey,"
I said. "Toots.
Sweetie.
Perhaps you misheard me.
I'm a genie And
the three wishes?
We're talking anything you want.
You ever dreamed of flying?
I can give you wings.
You want to be wealthy,
richer than Croesus?
You want power?
Say it.
Three wishes.
Whatever you want."
"Like I said,"
she said, "Thanks.
I'm fine." "Would you
like something to drink?
You must be parched
after spending
so much time in that lamp.
Wine?
Water?
Tea?"
"Uh..."
Actually, now she came to
mention it, I was thirsty.
"Do you have any mint tea?"
She made me some mint
tea in a teapot that
was almost a twin to the lamp
in which I'd spent the greater
part of the last thousand years.
"Thank you for the tea." "No
problem." "But I don't get it.
Everyone I've ever met, they
start asking for things.
A fancy house.
A harem of gorgeous
women-- not that you'd
want that, of course.
"I might," she said.
"You can't just make
assumptions about people.
Oh, and don't call
me toots, or sweetie,
or any of those things.
My name's Hazel."
"Ah!"
I understood.
"You want a
beautiful woman then?
My apologies.
You have but to wish."
I folded my arms.
"No," she said. "I'm good.
No wishes.
How's the tea?"
I told her that the mint tea was
the finest I had ever tasted.
She asked me when I'd
started feeling a need
to grant people's
wishes, and whether I
felt a desperate need to please.
She asked about my
mother, and I told her
that she could not judge me
as you would judge mortals,
for I was a djinn, powerful and
wise, magical and mysterious.
She asked me if I liked hummus,
and when I said that I did,
she toasted a pita
bread and sliced it up
for me to dip into the hummus.
I dipped my bread
slices into the hummus
and ate it with delight.
The hummus gave me an idea.
"Just make a wish,"
I said helpfully,
"And I could have a meal fit
for a sultan brought in to you.
Each dish would be finer
than the one before,
and all served
upon golden plates.
And you could keep the
plates afterwards."
"It's good," she
said, with a smile.
"Would you like
to go for a walk?"
We walked together
through the town.
It felt good to stretch my
legs after so many years
in the lamp.
We wound up in a public park,
sitting on a bench by a lake.
It was warm, but gusty, and the
autumn leaves fell in flurries
each time the wind blew.
I told Hazel about
my youth as a djinn,
of how we used to
eavesdrop on the angels
and how they would
throw comets at as
if they spied us listening.
I told her of the bad
days of the djinn wars,
and how King Suleiman
had imprisoned us
inside hollow objects--
bottles, lamps,
clay pots, that kind of thing.
She told me of her parents,
who were both killed
in the same plane crash, and
who'd left her the house.
She told me of the job,
illustrating children's books,
a job she'd backed into
accidentally, at the point
she realized she would
never be a really
competent medical Illustrator.
And of how happy
she became whenever
she was sent a new
book to illustrate.
She told me she
taught life drawing
to adults at the local community
college one evening a week.
I saw no obvious
flaw in her life,
no hole she could fill
by wishing, save one.
"Your life is good,"
I told her. "But you
have no one to share it with.
Wish, and I will bring
you the perfect man.
Or woman.
A film star.
A rich-- person--" "No need.
I'm good," she said.
We walked back to her
house, past houses
dressed for Halloween.
"This is not right," I told her.
"People always want things."
"Not me.
I've got everything I
need." "Then what do I do?"
She thought for a moment.
Then she pointed
at her front yard.
"Can you rake the leaves?"
"Is that your wish?" "No.
Just something you
could do while I'm
getting our dinner ready."
I raked the leaves into
a heap by the hedge,
to stop the wind from
blowing it apart.
After dinner, I
washed up the dishes.
I spent the night in
Hazel's spare bedroom.
It wasn't that she
didn't want help.
She let me help.
I ran errands for her, picked
up art supplies and groceries.
On days she'd been
painting for a long time,
she let me rub her
neck and shoulders.
I have good, firm hands.
Shortly before Thanksgiving, I
moved out of the spare bedroom,
across the hall, into the
main bedroom, and Hazel's bed.
I watched her face this
morning as she slept.
I stared at the shapes her
lips make when she sleeps.
The creeping sunlight
touched her face,
and she opened her eyes and
stared at me, and she smiled.
"You know what I never asked,
she said, "is what about you?"
"What would you
wish for if I asked
what your three wishes were?"
I thought for moment.
I put my arm around her,
and she snuggled her head
into my shoulder.
"It's OK," I told her.
"I'm good."
AMANDA PALMER: So, one last
tune for you guys, and then
and then we'll do questions
and talking and stuff.
And this is also-- all the
stuff we've done here today
is actually on the record.
Isn't it?
Or no, except for the
Calendar of Tales.
Yeah, but everything else is.
And so, as you can see, I play
the piano and the ukulele--
the ukulele not really
as good as the piano.
I'm a real fan recently of--
well, it's not a new idea,
but I think it's great to
play an instrument that you're
shitty at.
It's very liberating.
This is sort of a
song about that,
and it's called "The
Ukulele Anthem."
[MUSIC - AMANDA PALMER,
"THE UKULELE ANTHEM"]
AMANDA PALMER: Thank you.
ALAN LIGHT: So let's talk a
little bit about these shows,
these shows you're
playing and these
shows that you've recorded onto
this "Evening With" record.
Is it more interesting for
you guys to combine your work
or to combine your audiences?
NEIL GAIMAN:
Actually, the reason
why we did them was
a little bit of both.
We never get free time.
We're both strangely
busy people.
But, in 2011, we suddenly
found ourselves with 11 days
where we had to start
out in LA, and we
had to finish in Seattle, and
we didn't have anything to do.
And it was amazing.
And so, immediately we decided
to fill it by hiring a car
and just driving
up the west coast.
And we thought, well
we'll have a vacation.
And then we thought, well, if
we're going to have a vacation,
we'll get on each other's
nerves by day two,
so we need something to do.
And so that was the idea of
taking little theaters as we
went and just doing
"An Evening With."
And that, of course,
embiggened ridiculously very,
very quickly.
But what became fun was
the mingling the audiences.
It was like a wedding.
It was like that sort of --
"are you on the bride's side
or the groom's side" thing.
And we'd meet people
afterwards at the signings,
and we'd hang around
and say hello.
And there would be people
who would just ignore me
completely, head over to Amanda
with their Dresden Dolls CDs.
Then there'd be people who'd
ignore her and come over
to me with their Sandmans.
And then there'd be the people
who'd just come up and go,
can't believe you two--
my favorite writer.
Like, aw, this is just the best.
ALAN LIGHT: Given
that you've both
constructed these lives
that sort of enable
you to do whatever
you want, whenever
you want-- it's the remarkable
thing about it-- what is it
that these shows have
enabled you to do,
have brought out that's
different than any other forum?
AMANDA PALMER: That's
a good question.
It's fresh in my
mind right now--
we did a Reddit-- was
that two days ago?
Yeah, two days ago, thanks.
We did a Reddit two days ago--
NEIL GAIMAN: Several years ago
in out of internet time, but--
AMANDA PALMER: And
someone asked--
I've been talking a lot
publicly, nowadays, and writing
a lot, about internet nastiness.
And it's actually a
hot topic in general.
Not because I think
there's necessarily,
particularly any more
of it today than there
was last week or last year.
But it's so
pervasive that people
seem to be trying to figure
out, OK, well, clearly it's
not going away.
How the fuck do we deal with it?
Especially as artists,
and as women or whatever.
And we talked on
Reddit about how
Neil and I had our own
particular relationship
with our fans and
with our haters
before we met each other.
And then, we sort of inherited
new forms of hate when--
ALAN LIGHT: They're still
making new forms of hate.
AMANDA PALMER: I think,
maybe, subconsciously, it
was also a way of going
out in public and saying,
we're two people who are
going to do things together.
And, in a way, kind of like
the wedding, it was like,
you guys are going to
have to meet my husband.
He's a really, really nice guy.
And vice versa.
And I wanted them to see him.
I wanted them to know him.
NEIL GAIMAN: It was
really interesting,
I think, for us also because
we have both been getting up
on stage is in front
of audiences doing
the thing that we do for
years and years and years.
And if there's one thing that we
are both completely certain of,
it is that the buck stops
with us, with each individual.
You know, if it's my
reading or whatever,
anyone else can
have input, but I'm
the one that gets to decide
what I read, what happens.
And Amanda, gigging, it
all ends up with her.
And so, you suddenly
had these two people
who are completely used to being
the last authority-- questions
could be raised,
ideas could be had,
but, finally, it would
get to me or get to Amanda
and we'd say, well, actually
we'll do it like this.
And suddenly, we'd
get to the point
where Amanda would say, well,
we're going to do it like this.
And I'd say, no, we're not.
Or vice versa.
And--
AMANDA PALMER: Oh my god,
it's like being married.
NEIL GAIMAN: It was.
It was the most,
sort of, married,
bumping into each
other, and I think
it taught both of us
humility, especially me.
AMANDA PALMER: Oh, both of us.
NEIL GAIMAN: And
actually taught us
to cooperate in ways that,
I think-- it was nice,
it was like a pressure
cooker, because it was the one
area of our lives in which
we both reigned supreme,
and suddenly we had
to give that up.
AMANDA PALMER: Yeah, and also
I had a chip on my shoulder,
maybe, about, well,
I'm the stage person.
So I even thought
that, maybe, when
we would get into these
arguments about, like,
the chair should go here or
the chair should go there--
NEIL GAIMAN: We had
those arguments.
AMANDA PALMER: And we
did have those arguments.
That's one of the weird
things about being married
to an artist, or a person who is
used to doing big public events
or whatever, is that I
felt like the expert,
and Neil felt like the
expert, and we would sort of
be there going
like, but, but but,
but but-- You could look at
so many parts of the tour
and the recording
and the decisions
as a total marriage
metaphor, because a lot of it
was actually-- not the
arguments we would get into,
but just how we would actually
smooth things out and not
actually get angry at each
other and kind of learn
how to do the dance.
NEIL GAIMAN: Even doing
the Kickstarter video.
When we decided we were actually
going to do this properly,
we suddenly went, we
might as well record it.
And if we're going
to record it, we
may as well record it properly,
and why not go to Kickstarter?
This was in the relatively
early days of Kickstarter.
So we tried recording a serious
video in which we explained
what we were doing,
and why we needed
the money, and stuff like that.
And we did that about
three or four times,
and all we knew is
that, by the end of it,
we hated it and each other.
AMANDA PALMER: And Neil
had a terrible cold.
NEIL GAIMAN: But then,
time was running out,
and then we had to
do one suddenly.
We'd realized it was our
only chance together,
and I'd lost my voice, and
had this horrible cold,
and was sick.
And we were in Brighton, where
Amanda was about to do a gig,
so I grabbed a banana
from the dressing room,
we walked down onto
the beach, and Amanda
explained to the
world what we were
going to do in this Kickstarter
while I ate a banana.
AMANDA PALMER: It was perfect.
NEIL GAIMAN: And I think--
AMANDA PALMER: It was a
performance art Kickstarter
video.
NEIL GAIMAN: As Kickstarter
videos, it was the best.
AMANDA PALMER:
And also very much
in keeping with our stage
personas, which is-- he's
really good at being
the straight guy,
and I'm the obnoxious,
ridiculous one.
And we sort of
balance each other.
NEIL GAIMAN: I like to think
of it as English and American.
AMANDA PALMER: Ow.
Ow!
ALAN LIGHT: All right.
Well, coming off the
ropes from that one--
I inevitably will want to come
back to the Kickstarter stuff,
but I want to ask
you a little bit
about these modes of creativity.
And, I guess, Neil, even
within recent months
there's been the
novel, the comic book,
the Twitter stories-- all of
these different mechanisms
or constructions that you
use to get these stories out
in the world.
How do you determine,
and when do you
determine, what goes
where, what idea is then
going to manifest in which way?
NEIL GAIMAN: A
lot of the times I
have a vague idea going into it.
The medium actually defines what
goes into it a lot of the time.
A lot of the time I'm wrong.
I had two actual books come
out this year-- "The Ocean
at the End of the Lane" and
"Fortunately, the Milk,"
my children's book.
And both of them started
off as something else.
"Ocean at the End of the
Lane" was a short story
that I was writing to send
Amanda when she was recording
"Theater Is Evil," because
I missed her, and I thought,
I'll send her a short story.
It'll show her I love her.
She'll be impressed.
Better than flowers.
Except that it just kept
going, and by the time
I finished it, she'd
returned from Australia,
was mixing the album in
Dallas, and I did a word count
and discovered I'd written
a novel, accidentally.
"Fortunately, the Milk"
started out in my head
as a picture book.
And I just started writing it.
And I was writing
it in a notebook.
And whenever I felt like
I needed cheering up I'd
go to the notebook and I'd
write about 1,000 words
of "Fortunately,
the Milk," it would
make me smile, and then I'd put
it away and forget about it.
And when I got to
the end, again,
I typed it up,
looked at it, went--
this is much, much, much, too
long to ever be a picture book.
It's actually a book.
So in those cases
I was just wrong.
Sometimes there are things
where you sort of go, well,
look, if it's in your head
and it's got pictures in,
it's probably not a novel.
If the pictures
actually move and make
sounds, then maybe it's
television or a movie.
If you can keep
them kind of static,
then maybe it's
going to be a comic.
And sometimes I'll try something
in several different ways.
I'll have an idea
that I know works,
and I'll try it as a poem
and watch it fail as a poem
and go, OK, well, if
you're not a poem,
then maybe you're a
short story-- maybe
you're a comic, whatever.
I'll come back
and sometimes play
with things in two or
three different times
until I feel like
I've got it right.
ALAN LIGHT: I don't know
if this is the Amanda
version of that question,
but it seems related.
You've told the story
onstage and offstage
about writing "The Bed Song" and
the process and transformation
that came at the end of
making that song happen.
Can you tell that story and
talk about that a little bit,
which seems to me
also about, where
does the creativity take you?
AMANDA PALMER: Yeah.
"The Bed Song" is
interesting for me.
I wish I'd played
it for you guys,
because you'd have
some context, but it's
a solo piano song
on the new record.
And it's pretty simple
to explain, actually.
It's almost like a fictional
narrative of a couple
told in the first
person, basically,
starting at the beginning
of the relationship.
And it chronicles,
with each verse,
the way the beds change
in the relationship.
And it starts out, and
it's this crazy couple
at a party sleeping in a
sleeping bag at their friends'
house, and through the
shitty futon at college,
and through getting
married and getting
a proper bed in a condo.
And while this is all
happening, the relationship's--
NEIL GAIMAN:Dying.
AMANDA PALMER: Dying.
Encoldening.
I don't know,
becoming more distant.
And the bed just becomes
this metaphor of space.
And I don't usually
write songs like that.
But I'm so impressed
by Neil because he's
such a great fiction thinker.
And usually when I think
about ideas and songs,
it's always so personal.
And even my sort of
fictional work in the past
has always been like some
very, very close reflection
of myself.
But very close, so close
that you look at it,
and you see the ingredients, and
you see that it's not quite me,
but it might as well be.
NEIL GAIMAN: Close enough that
your mother can get irritated.
AMANDA PALMER: Exactly.
But "The Bed Song," actually,
I haven't experienced all of
those stages.
I've definitely been
in relationships
where distance
happened, but this
was like writing an epic poem of
all painful relationships ever.
And I was really proud of having
written it, because I was like,
actually I'm proud
that it's a good song,
but I'm actually
proud that I managed
to write a good work of fiction.
ALAN LIGHT: Which you
also sort of webcast,
Twitter-cast, the
writing of, right?
AMANDA PALMER:
Yeah, and so that's
another thing about the song.
So, another thing that happened
while writing the song.
And I got the idea for the song
probably a week or so before I
wrote it.
The idea popped in and the idea
of using the bed as a metaphor.
And I thought, aw,
that'll be a great song.
If I get that right,
And I sat myself down at the
piano one day to write it.
And up until that point,
I had had a real hangup
about what it meant to be a
good, disciplined creator.
Which is, at the moment of
creation, and at the moment
where I'm really going to
sit down and write a song,
I need to turn my phone off, not
be distracted, shut my computer
down, put all the
shit away, and write,
which is what real writers do.
And I have a huge
Twitter following
that I have a constant,
ongoing communication
relationship with.
And just this time,
I decided, you know,
fuck it, I'm going to actually,
instead of closing down,
I'm going to open up.
And I'm going to announce
to my Twitter feed
that I'm writing a song.
And actually, by
doing that, I feel
like I'm going to
have to be more
disciplined because they're
all going to kind of keep me
on task.
And they did.
And it's not like I set
up a webcasting station
at the piano.
They didn't watch my process.
But they knew, and
they were there.
And every 20 minutes
or so-- probably
took me three hours to write
the song, and every 20 minutes
or so I'd take a picture
of all my scratched
out words and the piano and
my fan base is great that way.
They were like a
bunch of cheerleaders
who were just sitting
there on Twitter saying,
this sounds amazing.
We're so glad you're writing.
We can't wait to hear the song.
And I realized I could do both.
And I could tap into the
enthusiasm of the internet
without letting it destroy
my creative process,
and that was a huge revelation.
And the song wound up being one
of the best I'd ever written,
I thought, and so I didn't
take that lesson lightly.
ALAN LIGHT: So one
more for each and then
we'll go to questions
for you guys,
so start organizing
your thoughts.
Inevitably, I must ask about the
famous, infamous, celebrated,
Earth-shattering
Kickstarter campaign,
and all of the attention
that it received,
more so than anything else.
That there was so much
talk and so many responses,
from-- we have seen the
future of the industry,
to she's a total hustler, to
every response you could have.
From this vantage
point now, what
do you take as the biggest
lessons from the $1 million
Kickstarter experience?
NEIL GAIMAN: Don't
give them free postage.
AMANDA PALMER:Yeah, don't
do free internet postage,
that's the big one.
I learned so many things
in so many departments,
and I could talk about it
for half an hour, so I won't.
And actually, my brain is
sort of prepped on this.
I was in Vienna last week
and doing a panel like this
on crowd funding and we got into
really dark, interesting talks
about social capital.
And a lot of the
conversation, lately,
that I've been involved
in and wondering about,
and what everyone's
wondering about
is-- what if you're not like me?
And I can say it's the future
of music, but it's my future.
I'm good at this, and I'm
good at communicating,
and I like hanging
out with my fans,
and I love tweeting all
day and I love blogging,
and I love using platforms
like Kickstarter.
That doesn't
necessarily mean it's
for everyone or
for every project.
And I think one of the
biggest-- not mistakes,
but sort of misguided things,
maybe, about the Kickstarter,
was that I drank the
Kool-Aid that my Kickstarter
success would translate
into commercial success.
And so I found myself
thinking that, in a weird way,
I wish I had just taken my fan
base for granted and done it
with them, instead of thinking
that I could use them as a step
to get to whatever that
next magical place was.
I had already
learned that lesson
six times over with
the record label,
and I thought it was going to
be different with Kickstarter,
that every time I would walk
into the office at Roadrunner
Records-- not very far from
here, and now nonexistent.
But they would say, this
is going to be the one,
this is the moment.
This is going to be the project
that is going to actually bring
you to the next place, which
is the place you want to be.
And I would go, oh, wow, great,
and an office of 30 people
seem to believe it, and seem
to believe that we should
be putting our energy not
into where we feel safe
and into those we love but
into foreign structures
so that we can go out
and conquer and be
an imperial band.
And actually, if I've
learned any lesson
it's that even those
closely around me,
very well-intentioned,
shouldn't be telling me
what my instincts are.
And I am very gullible.
So that was the biggest
one, because if I
had just done the Kickstarter
and delivered the record,
and not also paid
for giant videos
and not paid for huge
marketing campaigns
and not tried to reach
for the mainstream success
that my team all just flat
assumed that the record would
have, I think I would
have been happier.
NEIL GAIMAN: And richer.
AMANDA PALMER: And richer.
Yeah, but richer-- I don't
really care about richer,
but happier I do care--
NEIL GAIMAN: I
know, but there was
all of those people seem
to be assuming that you,
having had the Kickstarter,
you were now Uncle Scrooge-ing.
You had a swimming pool.
It was filled with dollars.
And you would take
off all your clothes
and plunge into
it like a dolphin.
AMANDA PALMER: That's a
wonderful image, Neil.
ALAN LIGHT: Maybe a song.
AMANDA PALMER: But yeah,
and if nothing else,
it also lifted the
rug up on how amazed I
was that really intelligent
people didn't understand
how business worked.
Like, it really amazed
me that smart journalists
at smart magazines
would be like, well, now
that you have $1.2
million in the bank, what
are you going to do?
And I'd be like, have you seen
the Kickstarter and the fact
that I have to manufacture
$800,000 worth of shit
and mail it to people--
and that it's a business?
And that has brought--
NEIL GAIMAN: I love the
guy on Reddit who asked,
you say you spent over
$100,000 manufacturing CDs,
yet you only asked for
$100,000 to start out with.
How can you explain that?
And I'm going, well if only
3,000 people had signed up,
and she'd only
had $100,000, then
she wouldn't have
had to manufacture--
it was a sort of strange thing.
AMANDA PALMER: Yeah,
and I fielded a lot.
And so the bigger question--
and I'm about to write a book,
and the book is
going to be centered
around these weird
new questions that
have come flooding into my life,
which is-- why do people think
art is so much different
from running a business?
And why is making a vinyl album,
in people's heads, so much
different than making an iPhone?
And why do artists get shit
for things that business people
don't?
And I can understand why.
And artists are weird.
And the way we feel
about commerce over here,
and just like, I will make you
this thing and it costs $19.95.
And the way people feel
about paintings or music
is definitely different.
But watching them
collide is fascinating.
ALAN LIGHT: And is
where the action is.
I mean that's where
we're living right now,
is in those questions.
Which brings me beautifully
to the final question
I was going to ask Neil
and not hog the microphone.
The other thing that
came out this year
was the publication of
the "Make Great Art"--
NEIL GAIMAN: My speech.
ALAN LIGHT: Commencement
lecture, yes.
So I'm curious.
We have a roomful here,
maybe of artists, but maybe
technology visionaries
and wizards and whatever
it is that they do
within these walls.
And I'm curious, without asking
you to deliver a speech that
will go viral around the world
and cause people to quote
from at numerous occasions--
would you modify,
or how would you
modify the ideas
that you spoke about in
that celebrated speech
for a room that's like this one?
NEIL GAIMAN: You
know, I wouldn't.
What was fascinating for
me about that speech was,
I gave a commencement
speech because I
was asked to give a
commencement speech--
I'd never given one before.
And I'd write it and
I'd show it to Amanda,
and she'd read it through and
she'd say, you can't say that.
And I'd say why not?
And she'd well that's
the kind of thing
they say in
commencement speeches.
And I wouldn't know.
So what I did was
simply take everything
I've learned in 30
years of being a writer
and stick it into a speech,
like-- that was easy.
And there is a bit
at the end where
I started explaining
that what you
do as an artist-- because it was
to the University of the Arts
and a graduating
class of artists-- is,
you make good art.
And that actually
should be your response
to all of the shit
you're going to run into.
You know-- husband leaves
you, make good art.
House burns down--
make good art.
Something wonderful
happens-- make good art.
That's what you do.
And what I loved,
once it went out there
and went viral, which is the
kind of unpredictable thing
that sometimes happens,
and happens in this case.
I'd see people on
Twitter, and on the web,
and on comments saying,
well I'm an architect.
Actually, it works if
you just cross out "art"
and make "architecture."
And someone else
is going, physics--
you can make good physics.
So, speaking as the proud parent
of somebody at Google who,
when I say to him, so, Mike,
explain to me what it is you're
doing again?
And he'll say,
well leaving aside
all of the secrecy
agreements, there
are a few things I can tell you.
And I say, OK, so tell me.
And he'll go, right, so-- waa
waa waa waa waa waa waa waa
waa.
It's like the adults
in Charlie Brown.
And after a while
he will realize
that my eyes have
completely glazed over,
and I'll say, well, could
you just give that to me
in terms that I understand.
He'll say, oh, Dad.
Well, you know what a
programming language is.
And I'll say well yeah, I know
what a programing language is.
He says, well,waa
waa waa waa waa waa--
So, I would, for this
gathered audience,
I would say make good waa
waa waa waa waa waa waa waa.
ALAN LIGHT: So if you guys
have questions and want
to go to the microphones,
that's why they're there.
In the meantime, just
quickly because somebody
will ask from the
fans for the news
hook is what's latest on
"American Gods'" progress
with HBO, and in
the last few hours
there's been lots of
Sandman movie talk, so--
NEIL GAIMAN: So,
"American Gods" is not
going to be-- there is
going to be a TV series.
It's not going to be with HBO.
I'm not yet at liberty to
say where it is going to be,
but it's awesome.
I can say that.
The "Sandman" movie rumors
are "Sandman" movie rumors.
And there was a saying when
I grew up in Sussex which
you would occasionally
hear old men say--
theoretically old women
could have said it too,
but I never heard them
But I did actually
hear our gardener say it.
He said, I've lived too
near the woods too long
to be frightened by an owl.
And "Sandman" and is now
in its 25th year and rounds
of internet rumors
every couple of years.
People say, what do you think
of the new "Sandman" rumors?
And I say, yeah, they're
"Sandman" rumors.
But haven't you seen
them, they're on the web.
And it's like, yes I've seen
them, and they're on the web.
And you know, 18 months ago
it was definite that Eric
Kripke's people were making
the "Sandman" TV series,
and it was definitely happening,
except that it wasn't.
As far as I can tell,
watching this-- loving
the mechanics of
an internet rumor--
The incredibly tentative rumor
that somebody nervously put up,
saying that they thought that
maybe David Goyer was thinking
about pitching a
"Sandman" take to Warners
and had possibly spoken
to or thought about Joseph
Gordon-Levitt being in some way
connected, which as far as I
can tell is the one-- is
actually what went up--
has transmuted like this
cosmic game of telephone
into people on
Twitter saying, well,
what are you doing about
the David Goyer Joseph
Gordon-Levitt movie?
And I'm going, nothing,
because it's all in your head.
I will believe the "Sandman"
movie when I'm actually
sitting in the audience
eating popcorn.
People saying things on
the internet is lovely,
but it's what they
do on the internet.
ALAN LIGHT: Lovely or not.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I loved the Judy Blume
song, that was awesome.
AMANDA PALMER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I
know there's lots
of tired questions you guys
get from doing interviews--
certainly none of
them were today.
Thank you for the
awesome interview.
Are there any
subjects that you guys
wish that people
would ask you about?
NEIL GAIMAN: I
sometimes wish they'd
ask more about the actual
mechanics of writing,
because there's all this
stuff that I know and love.
And most people don't
come up and say,
so let's talk about adverbs.
Stephen King says you
don't use adverbs,
but I've read your stuff and
you use adverbs all the time.
What do you-- what's with that?
You know that kind of thing,
where you sort of feel
like, oh, I can get into
the mechanics of my craft.
And nobody ever
wants to know that.
They just want to know
who was the forgotten god
in "American Gods,"
or whatever. which
is a different kind of thing.
AMANDA PALMER: Yeah,
mine's similar.
Especially given this
last year, even when
I would try to nudge journalists
or interviewers towards the,
you do know I made a record?
And we've spent 45 minutes
talking about Kickstarter,
and I know you think
it's fascinating,
and I find it
fascinating, but I really,
especially in this day and
age and being who I am,
it does get painful to
see the point-- which
is the music-- getting obscured
by the tech and the tools
and the house around it.
Because I'm really much
more proud of the record
I made than I am
of the Kickstarter.
But people forget that,
because the Kickstarter
is really big and shiny.
And sometimes I wish that people
would talk to me about actually
what it's like to do this
weird job, that doesn't really
have a name, that's like part
artist, part traveling person,
part talker to other people,
part Twitter curator, part
blogger.
And the only person I actually
get to talk about those details
to is him.
And I'm really lucky, because,
even though he's a writer
and I'm a musician, if you look
at hours clocked and the stuff
we do, the Venn diagram's
pretty-- we're very similar.
But it's funny, some of
my favorite conversations
lately have been with other
artists-- or reading articles.
I read an article
in The Guardian
by a young British
musician who's
in a band called
Chvrches, and she
was talking about how
it feels to be backstage
before a show on the
toilet with your phone,
crying, reading the
comments under some article
that she just wrote
about how people
are being sexist
towards her band.
And I was like, that's a very
real moment that I recognize,
which is that artists
are now having
to do jobs and communicate
in ways and deal
with stuff they didn't used to.
And that, in itself,
isn't really discussed,
how we juggle that.
And I think that's interesting
stuff to talk about.
And usually it
doesn't get that deep.
ALAN LIGHT: It's a
remarkable piece.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALAN LIGHT: The
Chvrches piece, yeah.
AMANDA PALMER: Yeah.
Let's go to this side.
AUDIENCE: Question for both.
Actually, first a comment.
With the "Sandman" movie, I
remember a number of years
ago you actually--
AMANDA PALMER: And they're off.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no no no no.
You actually made
the comment onstage
when someone asked you about it.
You used the words,
you don't want
to be the one boiling
your own baby.
NEIL GAIMAN: Barbecuing.
AUDIENCE: Barbecuing.
NEIL GAIMAN: I said I don't
want to barbecue my own baby.
I remember that, yes.
AUDIENCE: So, I
just want to say,
I've been reading your work
for, like, 20 years now
and it's still wonderful
and amazing and-- even
when I go back.
That said, I try to
sell a book to everybody
who reads your work
and I was wondering
if you might be able
to pitch it as well.
Why should people read
Gene Wolfe's "Peace"?
NEIL GAIMAN: Why should people
read Gene Wolfe's "Peace"?
Because it is smarter and
trickier than they are.
"Peace" is a beautiful
novel by Gene Wolfe, who
I think is one of the greatest
living American novelists.
Probably one of the greatest
living human novelists.
And "Peace" is an
early book of his,
and it's a book which,
the first time I read it,
I read as a beautiful,
bucolic set of memoirs,
heartwarming and sweet.
And then I went back to a few
years later and suddenly went,
this is not that book.
I completely misread it.
There is a dark, evil,
very, very nasty book hiding
inside this book.
That is so cool.
And the trouble
is, you don't want
to say any more than
that, because you
don't want to give
too much away.
You just want to
say like, read it.
And trust me.
AUDIENCE:Yeah.
NEIL GAIMAN: And it's
tricky and it's nasty.
AUDIENCE: I don't think
there's any book that I've ever
read and then
immediately reread,
because there's
just like-- oh wait.
NEIL GAIMAN:Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then for Amanda--
my wife, who also attended
Wesleyan, is an
artist and does kind
of a lot of design
and art-related stuff
to pay the bills.
But she feels weird about
that, especially since it's
hard to tell people
what she does.
Anyway, but she
specifically wanted
me to ask you when she
should be expecting the fraud
police to show up, because she's
been expecting them for a while
now.
AMANDA PALMER: Yeah, so
he's referencing something
that I actually-- I
gave a commencement
speech the graduation
year before Neil did,
and I talked about the
fraud police, which
is this phenomenon that--
I think it was actually
a friend of mine and I
came up with the term,
but it was that idea
that there really
are people who are going to
come knocking on your door
in the middle of the night
saying like, we know you don't
know what the fuck you're doing.
We're here to take you away.
That job
NEIL GAIMAN:In my head, they
were always going to knock
on my door and say, you're going
to have to get a real job now.
And I would.
I would go quietly
and get a real job.
AMANDA PALMER:Yeah, I mean,
it's funny in talking about all
of this stuff, about
art and business,
the idea that artists have of
themselves is usually so fucked
up, because of the main
cultural idea that everyone has
of artists.
And also in a weird--
not to get to meta,
but-- the way that everyone
thinks that artists have
this passionate
relationship with their art,
or this total purity, or
this-- pick an adjective.
And it's been great for me, now,
as an artist-- I'm going on 40.
And there are as many kinds of
artists as there are people.
They're just as insecure,
they're just as good
at, or bad at, business, good
at, or bad at, communicating.
And sure, there's some
things about artists
that you can see
that are similar,
but it was incredibly
liberating for me in my late 20s
to go like, oh I don't have to
act like this just because I'm
an artist.
I don't have to think
about myself this way,
or about my work,
or about my life.
And that "Bed Song" thing
is a perfect example.
I realized I had kind of
been buying into the idea
that artists do this and I'm
up in the garret with my wine
and my cigarettes creating
my-- and actually, it's
not like that.
It's work like anything
else-- you sit your ass down
and you do it.
And it's not romantic, and
it's not necessarily fun,
and you might not even
feel passionate about it.
And so once you can do enough
work on yourself as a human,
in the forgiveness department,
that you're not fitting
the picture that
you had, the fraud
police just-- You
still always fear
that, I think, in a little way.
But the more you work and the
more other people take you
seriously, the easier it gets.
NEIL GAIMAN: I was
actually in the audience
at her commencement
speech, and I misheard her.
And I went through the
entirety of her speech
thinking she was talking
about the "frog police."
Which were still doing the
same thing that the fraud
police did, they were just
these 6 foot high frogs who--
AMANDA PALMER:
Knocked on your door
in the middle of the
night telling you
that you had to get
a real fucking job.
ALAN LIGHT: You
would listen to them.
All right, I hate to do it.
I got the signal saying I
can take one more question,
so that would come
back to this side,
so, sorry to the other guys.
AUDIENCE: So, let's
talk about adverbs.
AMANDA PALMER: Shit.
AUDIENCE: Seriously, no, really.
So Neil, you write a lot of
imaginative, really interesting
worlds and settings,
but you rarely
reuse them, or
come back to them.
Do you ever miss the worlds
that you created and wish
you could come back
to them, and what
specific settings do
you miss the most?
NEIL GAIMAN: Absolutely, I do.
People think that
I have some kind
of weird moral high
ground, and that I'm not
the kind of writer
who does sequels,
and the truth is I'm always
the kind of writer who
plans to do sequels, and
would love to go back.
I just get sort of--
if, on the one hand
I have the choice between
something that I've done,
and I know how to do it,
and I can do it well,
and it now has an audience
who are waiting for more,
and a publisher who will
give me more money to do it--
and, on the other
hand, I have something
that I have no idea
if anybody wants,
that I don't know how to do,
I will always go, oh, shiny.
That's what I do.
Recently BBC Radio did an audio
adaptation of "Neverwhere"--
BBC Radio 4.
And I got to act in
it, which was amazing.
Much more amazing than that
was that James McAvoy, Natalie
Dormer, Sir Christopher Lee,
Bernard Cribbins, Anthony
Stewart Head.
The cast list is just a
who's who of amazing actors.
And it goes on and on and on.
And all of these
people were in it.
And I got to listen to it
when they'd finished it.
And I listened to the whole
six hours of BBC "Neverwhere."
And I went, this is great!
Why isn't there
any more of this?
And then I thought, oh, it's
because I never did any more.
So I went and dug out the first
page of a short story called
"Hoe the Marquis Got His Coat
Back" that I started in 2002
and abandoned, not
because it was bad,
but because I was
writing it in a notebook
that a fan had
given me with rose
petals bound into the paper.
And I discovered
that if you have
rose petals bound into the
paper, they clog your pen.
So I'd written a page and
a half and put it away.
It's true.
And so I finished that story and
it's 10,000, 11,000 words long.
And I gave it to George R.R.
Martin and Gardner Dozois
for an anthology called
"Rogues," which'll
be coming out next September.
And having done that,
I went, hang on,
I have an entire other
"Neverwhere" novel plotted,
I just never quite
got round to it.
I should definitely do that.
So, I really should
It's honestly
not because I don't mean to.
It's just, I get distracted.
ALAN LIGHT: Ladies and
gentleman of Google,
thank you for your time.
Everybody have a lovely weekend.
NEIL GAIMAN: Thank you so much.
ALAN LIGHT: Neil Gaiman
and Amanda Palmer.
NEIL GAIMAN: Thank
you very much.
AMANDA PALMER: Thanks, Alan.